[Music]
hello and welcome to this special
edition of the sky news daily podcast
with me dermot
now a dozen of our correspondents are
joining me over the next three episodes
to discuss some of the the biggest
stories and issues of the last year and
what a year it has been in 2021 now over
the next half an hour we're going to be
discussing themes surrounding covid
violence against women and sport and
joining me my panel on this podcast in
the studio with me our political editor
beth rigmey sky correspondent ashna
hurinag and joining us remotely our
economics and data editor ed conway
our special correspondent alex crawford
and health correspondent ashish josh
good to talk to you all got a lot to get
through so let's get on with that first
the the story of course that has
dominated our lives in the uk and indeed
the entire world we know what it is
the government is once again instructing
you to stay at home this is similar to
the lockdown of march last year the
number of deaths recorded from kobed in
the uk has surpassed a hundred thousand
we had to have a film with three coffins
in the same church on the same day
because we couldn't face going through
it three times it's going to take this
country
and the whole world a long time to
recover from this extraordinary economic
situation obviously it's been such a
long time and i just want to get on the
dance floor
the early indications we have of this
variant is that it may be more
transmissible than the delta variant
okay well let's go back to the beginning
of the year with you ashish first and of
course in the uk
an instant lockdown more or less schools
went back i think it was for a day and
then plunged back into lockdown the
disruption to education derma the
upheaval for all of these young people
who were expecting to go back to school
were told to stay at home
this cloud hanging over their exam
results and what would happen the
uncertainty
and that lasted all the way into the
early spring but certainly at the same
time we had the first
movings of this incredible machinery of
the nhs and the army and the doctors and
primary care and volunteers all coming
together to try and set up these amazing
incredible vaccination knobs those are
the images which are going to be seared
into my memory certainly at the
beginning of the year and then alex
crawford
the variance
delta originating or certainly
identified first of all in india and uh
you reported very graphically on the
effect it had and the shivers it sent
down the spine and still is of the world
well weirdly derma actually when we
arrived in india they were very much
calling it the british variant the uk
variant the uh they were
they were still it was still very early
days and they were very reluctant to say
that it was something that had
originated or mutated in india and we
arrived a couple of weeks before it
actually peaked in the middle of april
uh and uh within an hour of us arriving
in india we were sort of face to face
slap bang in front of
the world's worst nightmare of what
happens in the middle of a pandemic
where the infrastructure cannot cope
within an hour we were we were
witnessing
uh at least half a dozen people dying in
front of us on pavements without oxygen
without doctors uh families crying and
weeping and wailing uh it was
an absolute meltdown and it was the
apocalyptic version really was the
apocalyptic version of what happens in
the midst in the eye of a storm when the
country can't cope they have made loads
of um of mistakes you could argue
because they had a very severe lockdown
like much of the rest of the world
earlier
and they'd emerged out of it and thought
that they had beaten it that was the
that was the
the big
we can't imagine it now but back then
back in january and february
uh the prime minister of india was
boasting that they were in the end game
of coronavirus yeah indeed ashton i want
to get away from
the data and the big picture and some of
the human stories that of course you
reported on over the years you know
talking about vaccines there people
perhaps who who haven't been vaccinated
and then
the awful effects of that yeah we are
still seeing a huge amount of people who
um don't want to take the covert 19
vaccine for whatever reason there's been
a huge amount of reporting done on the
myths um around some of the fears people
playing on that mistrust that some
people have and it is a
multi-generational thing often but you
do have mistrust in some communities and
therefore they're fearful of this
vaccine when you look at the bigger
picture it is so clear that the vaccine
is our way out in many respects it can
save so many lives but what you there is
no doubt that the nation is going
through this and the world this
collective sense of mourning this grief
um and
it's hard i think to find somebody who
hasn't been impacted by the pandemic in
in some form you talked to some families
didn't you i mean they'd have really
been cut apart by it
destroyed by it and also families that
we've we've spoken to who
chose not to get the vaccine and have
then gone on to to die from covert 19.
so people in that scenario speaking to
them has been so eye-opening because
obviously they're having this moment of
real reflection now and it's taken the
loss of a loved one for them to go out
and get their vaccine and you're seeing
a lot of these stories where people are
saying
we didn't want to take it we chose not
to take it and please go out and do so
because look what it's done to our
family and yet still you you do have a
lot of people who are still hesitant i
spoke to a number of pregnant women only
yesterday who don't want to take the
cover 19 vaccine and it's going to take
a lot of work to win those people over
beth talk to me about the politics of it
all and let's look at it from the start
of the year we've got a prime minister
he was reluctant to lock down again in
january he was reluctant to stop flights
from india as delta started to spread it
was very eager to have the grand
reopening freedom day in england on july
the 19th but yet as we reach the end of
the year still many questions about what
happens next in terms of restrictions
absolutely don't i was actually uh
looking back on this year and it's so
odd in that none of us can really
imagine living without covid and so much
has happened in this year i can't keep
up with it myself and actually i went
back to march the 23rd that was the year
anniversary of the fast lockdown and i
said to the prime minister at that press
conference
what's your reflection about what's
passed and what's to come and he said
we'll be dealing with kovid certainly in
my case for years to come he called it
an extraordinary moment in our history a
deeply difficult and distressing
period then you're right we had the
route map out of lockdown that began in
the winter
last year or this year sorry and it's
run through and you're right freedom
days it was called july the 19th it was
postponed from june the 21st as they had
to deal with the delta variant and as we
chance upon christmas again this year
the government with a new dilemma of a
new variant and uh ed of course we can't
ignore the economic aspects of all the
all the lockdowns their fellow scheme
this time a year ago was still fully in
operation um that's gone um although
many of the other mitigations have gone
as well and of course the huge amounts
of public money that have been spent on
trying to deal with it uh what effect
does that have overall on the economic
outlet yeah i mean like the weird thing
about last year is in economic terms
because of the furlough scheme because
the entire economy was kind of put into
hibernation the kind of economic story
in terms of unexpected news things apart
from just how scary those numbers were
was actually not quite as big as as you
might have expected this past year it
has been really big just because we've
started to see the economies reopen
again you've seen the massive economic
bounce and at the same time we're seeing
all sorts of weird things happen with
you know around the global economy stuff
that no economists had expected you know
supply chains basically not functioning
people running out of semiconductors car
companies having to shut down production
because they don't have enough inflation
rising to an extraordinary high gas
prices going up to the highest level
they've basically ever been
and you're in this new
new but this weirdly familiar world
where we're talking about whether we're
back in the 1970s what's going to be
interesting in the next year is first of
all what happens obviously with the
variance and whatever restrictions
remain in place at the start of the year
but secondly do central banks like the
bank of england or the federal reserve
need to start raising interest rates
over this period and does that in turn
bring them into conflict uh with
governments and do we start to see that
difficult dynamic all over again i i say
difficult for me as a as an economics
reporter i think would be fascinating
but but blimey this is this is stuff
which is quite unfamiliar to a lot of
people inflation growth like that we
haven't seen that for a long time okay
so so much to watch out for in the next
year
so many dimensions involving covid ed
alex ashish thank you very much indeed
for the time being and now we move on to
one of the stories that uh
shocked the entire nation in 2021
serving police constable has tonight
been charged with the kidnap and murder
of sarah everard
[Music]
sarah's kidnapped rape and murder was
one of the most dreadful events in the
190 year history
of the metropolitan police service let's
pray every day and work every day to
make sure nobody's name ends up on this
list again
[Music]
ashton let me ask you a personal
question about uh sarah overall the the
atrocity the murder um
you know i've got daughters your age and
i know that you know how deeply it
affected them it affected us all of
course but you know they
now
really think very hard about
walking home
about who knows where they're going all
kinds of things i i you know i know that
they've been they've been in
women's and young girls minds for for
many times but this really brought it
home didn't it yeah it didn't it also
was a moment where everybody realized um
that these were conversations and daily
thoughts that women and girls
have you know
where are you going at night telling
friends to me to be aware of your
location carrying your keys in your hand
just before you get home and making sure
it's you know you don't have a lot of
time on your own outside your front door
just getting in as quickly as possible
sharing your taxi journey with your
friends it's it's consistently it's
quite hard work actually isn't it when
you think about it but it's the daily
occurrences people are genuinely so
affected by
what they've seen this year and we have
seen this
cascading amount of anger frustration
huge amount of emotion behind what we've
seen this year fueling the conversation
around violence against women and girls
and it has been a really bleak fight to
try and get movement on this this year
but we have seen a lot of movement but
of course it all started back um with
sarah everard being
brutally murdered in the way that she
was
all of those details began to paint the
most horrific horrific
um image and also story and now whenever
you walk past the band stand at clapham
common which of course became a bit of a
symbol in itself didn't it you can't
help but think about what about her
you really can't
and uh i mean it threw up so many big
questions for for the government as well
the complexity around it
is how do you actually begin to try and
tackle something that is clearly so
deep-seated
in society and so some of the work we
have done as a channel
over the past
year is of course report this case ask
questions of the met and also begin to
ask about what government can do but
also culturally uh what needs to change
that's a really interesting thing you
raised there because i think it was an
eye-opener you know from from from the
male side of the equation you know the
you know particularly when we had didn't
we we had the that schoolgirl campaign
just pointing out how routine sexual
harassment
was throughout their school careers and
much worse
of course last time i checked the
femicide census
129 women have been killed by men in the
uk since the beginning of this year
so
it
pulls up i guess the importance and the
the the touch i think you called it
touch the touch piper the touch paper i
mean i i'd say a couple of things about
this the first one is in the panel we
did with mps about violence scopes from
the girls some of the things that they
want to change culturally and in terms
of legislation jess phillips who of
course
campaigned so prominently and
effectively
against domestic violence and violence
against women and girls you know the
thing that struck me in that
conversation she we had was she said the
thing is everyone knows a victim
that means everyone knows a perpetrator
and that is the conversation that we're
not having
at the moment as a society and that's
about the cultural change that we need
to
perhaps begin to bring in and discuss
and then the second thing is just in
terms of of course government can't fix
every problem and particularly societal
problems
but there is calls about what they can
actually do in terms of strengthening
legislation in terms of making it a
police priority to deal with sexual
harassment do they make harassment of
women and girls in the street a crime
uh so it becomes less
acceptable do they in the online harms
bill that's going to come into
parliament next year begin to make
things like cyber flashing when people
send
unsolicited
pictures unwanted to teenage girls and
and women do they make that a crime so i
think that there will be a body of work
in the next year about what they can do
as a government what mps can do to try
and put a structure around this more
substantively but ultimately dumber it
is a cultural change as well about what
is permissible and what is not
permissible and maybe it does start with
harassment of women and girls in the
streets okay well said beth ashley thank
you both very much indeed we're coming
up next on the podcast we look at the
sporting controversies of 2021
[Music]
well joining me for this part of the
podcast is sky sports correspondent tom
parmenter but before we talk to tom
let's listen first to some of this
year's sporting moments
i know that the pain that i went through
for the next few months
no one could ever ever put me through
that pain again it's an absolute
disgrace and honestly we have to wrestle
back the power in this country from the
clubs at the top of this league watching
england play is normally a burden of
suffering and tonight it was no
exception it means so much to me to be
here with the trophy it was always a
dream to win a grand slam
[Music]
plenty to discuss then tom let's start
though with yorkshire county cricket
club and you know one of the titans of
english county cricket embroiled in this
racism row well derby i think this was
the year that cricket reset and had to
have a good hard look at itself and it's
i think revolutionized cricket in
yorkshire given the testimony that azeem
rafiq their former player put forward to
mps in westminster in november it was a
searing account that
stopped people in their tracks within
the game of cricket and far beyond it
just the appalling catalogue of racism
that azim rafiq suffered through his
career and largely kept quiet about a
lot of the time but
i think it was yorkshire's inability to
handle that allegation of racism and in
a report they tried to put the context
forward of the p word for being used for
example as friendly banter and that was
the point at which people stood up
notable politicians included and said no
it is not friendly banter and
it prompted
a clean sweep of people
leaving headingly in disgrace at the
zenith of this racism scandal that the
likes of which cricket has never seen
before and i think it was one of those
that cut through to dinner tables across
the country and forced people to have
some very hard conversations
and let's talk about football now then
tom euro 2020 of course great to see it
back and crowds back and great to see
many of the big games including the
final of course in england at wembley
and england in that final but then the
other side of it the experience in the
final that the thugs that that broke in
and then the three missed penalties by
those young black england players and
the abuse they suffered it was england's
path to the final that stood out as
just an extraordinary run that gareth
southgate
got them on and southgate has managed to
do something quite spectacular really
and as much as
they're a team that the nation of
england can now be proud of not just for
the way they play football and the fact
that they're contenders but also the way
they conduct themselves as a group of
people off the pitch and yeah there were
some great moments wasn't it but as you
say what made it different was the very
marked markedly different atmosphere
outside the stadium for that final
around 2000 people broke into the
stadium they pushed through 17 entrances
to get in without tickets creating a
really dangerous situation but also one
that i think did mar the occasion
certainly and afterwards as you say
three high-profile black footballers
missing penalties led to a
a really ugly spectacle on social media
of abuse but i think what we should also
remember is what happened in south
manchester at the marcus rashford mural
in the days that followed the of course
there was a lot of hate
around that final that came out in so
many different ways but the love that we
saw at that mural and
other clubs as well
um as those players have got back to
life in the premier league well
a lot of hate but a lot of love as well
indeed and what a year it was tom for
the super league
the super league that didn't really get
going did it no they didn't consult the
fans and they thought i think the clubs
that they had strength in numbers
because they'd all signed up to this but
actually what it prompted and i remember
being outside anfield liverpool's ground
when the fans were putting up banners on
the gates behind the cop saying r.i.p
liverpool football club
and you think this is a huge
fight back from the fans they were
galvanized
to the point where they
really mobilized and took action and
made that point very forcefully indeed
and now tell me this
this time a year ago you got to be
honest even the you know the sports
expert you are had you ever heard of
emma radicano we all have now but i mean
boy she just burst onto the scene
originally at wimbledon and now she's a
grand slam champion
it was the standout story from nowhere
in
2021 and emmerdale i think i like
everyone else did google
emma rudykin she was one of the most
googled names
during this year and what a story it was
she of course put in a really strong
performance in wimbledon then pulled
away um from the competition she wasn't
quite right and then just seemed to
waltz into
new york
no great expectations and just made it
look so so easy and she's such a
composed young
woman who
just kind of blitzed the opera
opposition in a way that i don't think
really has ever been done before you
have so many people within tennis saying
that this is so hard to do and she's
making it look so easy tom thank you
very much indeed and uh just let me
remind you before we end this uh podcast
that uh these podcasts are available on
demand wherever you normally get your
podcasts from on the next podcast we'll
be discussing global security the
migrant crisis and the year's big
political stories this edition let me
tell you it was produced by annie joyce
along with felix forbes and directed by
kevin donaldson thanks for listening
[Music]